but now you've made the choice to bring
your children back to Australia yeah
yeah so would they all born in America
then you brought them back no my
daughter was born here in London
actually yep and then the boys were born
in America and we moved back to
Australia and now you've posted pictures
online and it basically was bringing
your children back there that wise like
you pick that's your house that's yeah
one of the bedrooms here is it one of
the children's bedrooms occasionally
yeah since that snake lives there is
that in your house it is yeah yeah they
better than paparazzi though those
animals okay I would take paparazzi over
this writer in the snake yeah you know
that snake the the what you don't say
we'd had a couple of drinks that night
when we discovered that snake in the
bedroom and I'm lost and again what is
it and someone's like it's a brown snake
which can kill you you know very quickly
someone's like now it's a tree python
it's something else is this and I just
launched into like action mode grabbed
it by the tail picked it up and if one
starts freaking out and it starts to
kind of coil itself back up toward me
which is getting ready to strike and I'm
everything at what the hell am i doing
so I just kind of threw the snake back
into the bedroom shut the door we don't
go in that bedroom anymore
I ordered up
[Music]
you